>> Katie: IT'S NOT JUST FREE
COLLEGE AND FREE HEALTH CARE,
DEMOCRATS ARE PROMISING VOTERS
FREE CASH.
THEY WANT TO GIVE FEDERALLY
FUNDED SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO EVERY
CHILD WHEN THEY ARE BORN.
THEY ARE PROMISING $1,000 PER
MONTH.
IT TURNS OUT, THESE POLICIES
DON'T WORK AS PROMISED.
SURPRISE.
FOR EXAMPLE, NEW YORK CITY
BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING AFTER
HIKING THE MINIMUM WAGE TO $15
AN HOUR.
THE GREAT ECONOMIST SAID THAT IF
THE GOVERNMENT WAS IN CHARGE,
THEY WOULD EVENTUALLY RUN OUT OF
SAND.
THEY THINK THERE'S MONEY FOR
EVERYONE AND THAT WE ARE GOING
TO PAY FOR IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THEIR
GREATEST CASH PUSH?
>> Greg: THE GREAT THING ABOUT
CAPITALISM IS THAT IT CAN ALLOW
FOR A LITTLE BIT OF SOCIALISM.
THE PROBLEM WITH THESE
CANDIDATES RIGHT NOW IS THEY SEE
THE SOCIALIST PART AS A
REPLACEMENT FOR THE ENGINE OF
CREATION OF WEALTH.
IT'S LIKE THEY THINK YOU CAN
HAVE A LIFE PRESERVER WITHOUT
THE LIFEGUARD.
BUT THE LIFEGUARD THROWS THE
LIFE PRESERVER OUT THERE.
THE THING IS, CAPITALIST WITH
SOCIALISM AWESOME.
>> Katie: IT WILL EVENTUALLY
TAKE OVER THE ENTIRE SYSTEM,
BECAUSE IT COMES A SITUATION
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT PROMISES
THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU MORE
MONEY.
THAT MEANS THEY ARE TAKING MONEY
FROM OTHER PEOPLE IN ORDER TO
GIVE YOU THESE TAX CREDITS THAT
YOU WANT.
WE WANT YEAH, THEY WILL SAY THAT
THEY CAN TAKE CARE OF YOU, BUT
THEY ARE REALLY JUST TRYING TO
TAKE CARE OF YOU.
BECAUSE IF EVERYONE DEPENDS ON
THE GOVERNMENT FOR EVERYTHING, A
HOUSE, THEN THERE IS NO ROOM TO
BREATHE.
YOU HAVE TO THAN VOTE FOR THE
PARTY IN POWER.
THAT'S WAS GIVING YOU ALL OF
YOUR LIFESTYLE AT THAT POINT.
AND THEN, WHEN THE SOCIALISTS
TAKE CONTROL, THEY DESTROY THEIR
OPPOSITION.
THAT'S WHAT SOCIALISM DOES.
ONCE THEY TAKE POWER, IT CREATES
A PERMANENT ROLE IN CASH.
THEN THEY CAN GET RID OF THE
BORDERS.
THEY CAN GET RID OF CAPITALISM.
THEY CAN GET RID OF RELIGION.
THEY CAN GET RID OF ANY
OBSTACLE.
IF YOU OPPOSE SOCIALISM, THEY
WILL BLOCK YOU, THEY WERE SENT
TO YOU, AND THEY WILL BOYCOTT
YOU.
THAT'S THE THREAT.
TO GREG'S POINT, A SAFETY NET.
SOME OF THE GREATEST
INSPIRATIONAL CREATIONS AND
INNOVATIONS HAVE COME FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE MAYBE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
MAYBE TOOK A RISK HERE, BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO LIFT THEMSELVES
UP.
THAT'S HOW ENTREPRENEURIAL SHIP
WORKS.
PEOPLE GO OUT THERE ON A LIMB
AND MAYBE BORROW SOME MONEY OR
RAISE SOME MONEY OR PUT ALL OF
THEIR MONEY INTO ONE POCKET.
THAT'S WHEN YOU BUILD WEALTH.
AND THEN YOU HAVE SOCIALISM, YOU
DON'T GET THAT.
>> Katie: THE FOUNDER OF
STARBUCKS GREW UP IN THE
BROOKLYN HOUSING PROJECTS.
DEMOCRATS WHO STILL BELIEVE IN A
JUSTIFIABLE SMALL SAFETY NET FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT.
AND THAT PEOPLE LIKE CORY BOOKER
AND ELIZABETH WARREN AND SANDERS
WHO REALLY WANTS TO GIVE AWAY
EVERYTHING BASED ON THE POLICY
THAT WE WILL TAX THE RICH.
>> Donna: I THINK THAT'S AN
INTERESTING PROPOSAL.
I DON'T LOOK AT THESE DEBATES
AND SAY, THIS IS A SOCIALIST.
>> Katie: NONE OF THEM?
>> Donna: NO.
WHAT I SEE IS IF THE COUNTRY IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ONE, HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY AMERICAN
GETS A HEAD START IN LIFE.
TWO, HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT EVERY
AMERICAN, NOT JUST THOSE WHO ARE
WELL OFF, HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A FAIR SHARE OF THE
MIDDLE-CLASS.
AND THEN, LASTLY, WHEN WE SPEND
GOVERNMENT MONEY, THE DEFICIT IS
NOW AT 39%.
WE KNOW THAT CORPORATE TAX
RECEIPTS ARE DOWN.
WE KNOW A LOT ABOUT, GREG AND I
WERE TALKING AND AGREEING ABOUT
THE TARIFFS.
HOW WE WANT TO GET INTO A BIG
LARGE CONVERSATION ABOUT CHINA
AND THE TARIFFS.
BUT WHEN THE DEMOCRATS PROPOSE
THESE IDEAS, AND ONCE UPON A
TIME, REPUBLICANS USED TO
PROPOSE IDEAS THAT PEOPLE
THOUGHT WOULD CREATE CHANGE.
NIXON CREATED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME.
BUT WHEN DEMOCRATS PROPOSE THESE
IDEAS, THEY ARE TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
WHAT MAKES CERTAIN PEOPLE
UNCOMFORTABLE, I HAVE SUPPORTED
BILL CLINTON, WHO BROUGHT THE
DEFICIT DOWN.
I LISTEN TO DEMOCRATS WHO COME
FORWARD WITH IDEAS.
IF WE CAN PAY FOR IT.
>> Katie: IT'S INTERESTING TO
SEE THAT THERE ARE
PRIVATE-PUBLIC PARTNERSHIPS WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE PROGRAMS.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT MAYBE --
>> Dana: I THINK OF THE BOTTOM
LINE IS, NO ONE THINKS THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO LOSE AN ELECTION BY
PROMISING TO SPEND MORE MONEY.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF HOW YOU
ARE GOING TO SPEND THE MONEY.
SOCIAL SECURITY GOING FORWARD.
THERE ARE WAYS TO DO THAT.
NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT THAT
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE JUST
REMEMBER, THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE